- Hey guys, Dr. Mike Varshavski here.
Welcome to another episode
of the Wednesday Checkup.
In the past, I made a
COVID-19 fact checking video
on politicians, media,
even conspiracy theorists.
But today, I wanna focus
on President Trump.
And the reason I'm doing this
is not because of a political motivation,
but simply because he's the
leader of the United States,
he's in charge of making
a lot of the decisions
that affect you and I
in our day-to-day lives;
funding, testing, decisions
about potential treatments
and vaccinations.
And I think it's important to be critical
of our leaders so that we
can hold them accountable
to the statements and
the decisions they make.
I've been following the media reports
very closely surrounding COVID-19.
There's been heavy reporting
both in the United States and outside
talking about how America has failed
in the COVID-19 pandemic.
And while there's certainly truth to that,
we need to be fair.
No one can be truly
prepared for a pandemic,
we need to put that out there.
Also, hindsight is 20/20 and everyone
loves to play Monday morning quarterback.
That being said, President Trump has made
several inaccurate statements
that I'm gonna cover here today.
As a leader, you wanna project confidence,
you wanna project being
alert, not anxious.
However, that doesn't
mean we should downplay
truly serious issues.
And throughout this pandemic,
the messaging from President
Trump has been this.
- I think that's a problem
that's gonna go away.
It's going to disappear.
It will go away.
It's gonna go away.
You know it is going away.
It is going away, this is gonna go away.
It's gonna go, it's gonna leave.
- COVID-19 is gonna go away
won't be a problem for the rest our lives,
but to continually say this
in the midst of pandemic
when hundreds of thousands
of lives are being lost,
millions of people are getting infected,
it's just not an accurate
representation of what's going on.
You're talking points have to change
when you get new numbers in.
When I tell you at home to
not look at numbers everyday,
that's because I don't
want you becoming anxious
over each of these numbers going up.
But as the President of United States,
a person who's in charge of making
really important day-to-day decisions,
you have to be looking at these numbers
and seeing that this
problem isn't going away.
In fact, I think where
President Trump showed
the least amount of
accuracy in his speaking
was on the day that I published
my video two weeks ago.
COVID cases are spiking,
people are dying, and the
second wave isn't even here yet.
And here's what President
Trump said that same day.
- It's dying out.
It's fading away, it's going to fade away.
- Fast forward now to two weeks later,
the problem hasn't gone away.
It's actually gotten so bad
that the peak of COVID-19 is
higher than it was in April.
We have to take this virus seriously.
Because if we don't,
you know what happens?
It starts spiking again.
Exactly as it is happening right now.
I've consistently preach
that we need personal responsibility.
A serious level of responsibility
in order to stop or at
least slow down this virus,
meaning that we need to
socially distance ourselves,
we need to wear masks, wash our hands.
That being said, there is still something
that our government needs to do
and that's testing.
That's their responsibility.
We need to have testing
supplies available,
and we need to make it out of price
that's affordable to everybody.
In fact, it probably should
be covered by our government,
like it is in many other countries.
President Trump is going on stage
and saying things like this.
- We've tested now 25 million people.
Here's the bad part.
When you test the, when you
do testing to that extent,
you're gonna find more people,
you're gonna find more cases.
So I said to my people,
"Slow the testing down, please!"
- I can't imagine anyone at the CDC
or any respectable medical agency
hearing our president saying
we should slow down testing
and taking him seriously.
Here's what his staff has said.
- It was a comment that he made in jest,
it's a comment that he made in passing."
- It was tongue-in-cheek, come on now.
Come on now, that was tongue-in-cheek.
- I understand that there's
not much of a sense of humor
at CNN center, but the
president was joking.
- So let's say he's joking, why?
You're the leader of our nation.
We're looking to you for information.
A lot of people trust you.
And then after his staff
says it was a joke,
President Trump says this.
- [Interviewer] At that
rally when you said
you asked your people
to slow down testing,
were you just kidding
or do you have a plan
to slow down testing?
- I don't kid.
Let me just tell you.
Let me make it clear.
- So he's not kidding.
On top of it, when President Trump says,
"The numbers are going up
because we're testing more,"
that is a fallacy.
We are catching more cases.
But at the same time,
we're having more and more sick people
and virus transmission.
That is showed by increased
hospitalization rate
and an increased positivity rate
on the people who we are testing.
And in fact, President
Trump leads us to believe
that we have the biggest
testing capacity in the world.
We're eighth in per-capita
testing in the world.
Not number one, not number two, eight.
So we could do a better job.
And we certainly shouldn't
start slowing things down now
when the virus is at its
highest peak it has been.
Let's chat mortality rates.
Just last week, President Trump tweeted,
"Coronavirus deaths are way down.
Mortality rate is one of
the lowest in the world."
We aren't the lowest in the world.
We're somewhere in the mid-30s.
So we are not the best in
the world by any means.
I'm not even a huge fan of comparing
all of these numbers.
There's many countries in the world
that don't do a great job
in keeping exact deaths,
rates, certificates of death.
There's all sorts of
biases that come into play,
but that being said, we're
not number one anyway.
Coronavirus deaths, are they way down?
Well, they're down and we kind
of expect them to come up.
The reason I'm saying this
is 'cause we see the cases going up,
but the deaths aren't going up.
So President Trump is taking
this as a positive sign.
But I approach that with a
little bit of skepticism.
Usually, there's a lag time
between COVID-19 initial infection
and then deaths because it takes time
to succumb to the virus,
and then it takes time
to report that death.
Second, we're seeing a lot of young folks
get infected with this virus,
and generally speaking they
have a lower mortality rate
than the people who are
over the age of 50 or 60.
And then the final point is,
we have some treatments out there.
Remdesivir, dexamethasone, both treatments
that are being used in the severely ill,
hoping to prevent or
lower the chance of death.
We also learned how to
manage ventilators better.
In the beginning of this pandemic,
this was a novel virus.
We were learning, we were
trying different settings.
As we've established better parameters,
we've done better at taking
care of patients with COVID-19.
I hope that President Trump is right
and that the deaths do
continue trending downward,
but base on the information
we have at hand,
I don't think we can make
that prediction just yet.
- Coronavirus, right?
(crowd yelling)
Kung flu, yeah?
(crowd cheering)
- What's the purpose
of calling it kung flu?
You're not a standup comedian.
I want to laugh at ourselves,
at our problems, at our pain,
I believe it's therapeutic,
but not right now.
Not when the country is polarized
we need to bring together.
This isn't effective at anything
except rallying his base.
- Covid, COVID-19, covid,
I said what's the 19?
COVID-19, some people
can't explain what the 19.
COVID-19, I said, "That's an odd name."
- There's nothing odd about COVID-19.
19 stands for the year
that it was found, 2019.
It's almost as if President
Trump wants to demean this virus
so much that it's not as powerful
taking the power away from his campaign.
- But I get a lot of tremendously
positive news on the hydroxy.
- I've talked about hydroxychloroquine
many times on this
channel and on television.
It really bothered me when President Trump
called it a game changer
without having any real good
evidence to back that up.
And because of that, patients
took it unnecessarily,
potentially had negative
effect as a result.
And really saw limited benefit.
- You know the expression I've used, John?
What do you have to lose?
Okay, what do you have to lose?
- Your life.
Medications, even ones that have a known
safety profile have side effects.
I've had many patients contact me
from home when they were quite sick
and said they didn't
wanna go to the hospital,
they just wanted me to
prescribe hydroxychloroquine
because they saw President
Trump make statements like this.
And it took a lot of counseling
to explain what they could lose.
They can get arrhythmia,
they can lose their lives
as a result of this arrhythmia
because they're taking this medication
without getting an EKG first.
There's a lot of reasons why doctors
don't prescribe medications willy-nilly
and one of them is side effects.
That's probably the most
important one of them all.
Let's talk second wave.
It's at the tip of everyone's tongue,
we're all worried about it,
what's the deal with the second wave?
Here's what our politicians think.
- There is no second wave coming.
It's just hot spots
they send in CDC teams.
We've got the testing procedures,
we've got the diagnostics,
we've got the PPE,
and so I really think it's
a pretty good situation.
- Only Larry Kudlow can
go on television say,
"It's a pretty good situation,"
when we're hitting the biggest peak
we've had with COVID-19 cases.
It just doesn't make sense to me.
You're lying to yourself.
And in fact that's not the first time
Larry Kudlow has went on TV
and said something quite inaccurate.
- We have contained this.
I won't say air-tight, but
pretty close to air-tight.
- No, Larry Kudlow.
It's July and we still
have not contained this.
We're still experiencing all time highs,
despite the European Union
having a very low number of cases.
So we're clearly doing something wrong
and we have to be forthcoming
and honest about it.
But Larry Kudlow did say
one thing accurately.
There is no second wave.
But that's only because we
haven't even left the first wave.
The cases of COVID-19
spiked in the United States
we were happy they didn't spike that high.
We did all the social distancing,
and then we relaxed everything
and what do you know?
It just continues going right back up.
How has Larry Kudlow and President Trump
not changed their talking points
when the numbers are clearly going up.
We shouldn't be using COVID-19
as a chess piece in a political game.
We need to be looking at
these numbers honestly,
we need to be giving accurate
information to the public,
so they can make the best
decisions and actions
for themselves and their families.
Until we can put our
political nonsense aside,
we will not get anywhere.
Because the general public is confused.
I watch media, I'm confused.
I have to read dense research
in order to figure out what's going on.
The average person cannot do that,
therefore they're led astray.
We need a non-bias approach to COVID-19.
Let's stop playing the blame game
and just give the accurate information
of what's going on and
accurate non-political snapshot
as well as some guidelines
that aren't political as well.
Covering your face in public
to protect a community
is not a political statement.
You do not need to put on a
"Make America Great Again" hat
and put the mask over your eyes
to show how cool you are.
And at the same time,
if you see someone not wearing a mask,
yelling at them won't
help the situation either.
Explaining to them why the mask
is important could be a step,
but yelling at them is only
gonna make the problem worse
and the polarization
continue to trend upwards.
We need to do this smartly,
non-politically, and in a scientific way.
All in all, I have this final
message for President Trump.
You are the leader of the United States.
The country that I call home
that my family escaped to from Russia.
Your responsibility to
people to be honest,
to be forthcoming with information
that we can use to protect ourselves
and our family members.
Please avoid sarcastic,
jokey, or even mean rhetoric
when talking about COVID-19.
It creates confusion and confusion
in the midst of a pandemic
costs people their lives.
I'm a front line healthcare worker.
The last thing I wanna see
is my patients get sick
or even my colleagues get sick.
You have the ability to
bring this nation together.
But you have to do that by starting
to be honest, forthcoming,
and unifying in your message.